il est 9h30 quand le peloton
d'intervention interrégional de la
gendarmerie déclenché l'opération depuis
6 heures ce matin retraité de 75 ans
s'est retranché avec plusieurs fusils en
sa possession dans sa maison de quétigny
situé derrière le centre commercial du
cap vert c'est sa femme qui a pu donner
l'alerté après avoir entendu une
détonation
le quartier est bouclé et le forcené ne
répond pas aux négociateurs avec grenade
assourdissante et bélier ils pénètrent
dans la maison et découvre l'homme sans
vie on avait juste des éléments comme
quoi il était armé puisque apparemment
il y avait des fusils à l'intérieur du
domicile
donc à partir de ces éléments là nous
avons immédiatement pris les mesures de
sécurité nécessaires
lorsqu'on l'a retrouvé effectivement il
était décédé avec donc un fusil à pompe
à l'intérieur du domicile c'est que
justifier notre intervention renforcée
par le pi2g sûr sur cette intervention
décrit comme taciturne par ses voisins
l'homme ancien instituteur en afrique du
nord ce serait donc donné la mort avant
l'intervention des forces de l'ordre